good
[Applause]
morning I woke up last Wednesday on the
floor of the Vera Project after a very
very brief nap before that I was talking
to some people about the show I just
played how was the show the show was
awesome yeah it was hello stranger
playing my guitar you're volunteer V
thank you very much for staying this
late you're welcome it was a fun show I
played deathly how five times at this
show five times and I played it too
before that I was crowd surfing and then
before that I was playing bass guitar
and then before that I was watching
Harry and the Potters rock out and
before that I was listening to them tell
horrible jokes Hey what how did Olivia
from the cosmic show get sorted into
that's so Ravenclaw before that kimy
dosson was giving me presents I have
accepted your gifts kimya Dawson but
before that I was playing a show though
I spent most of my time talking during
that particular show how's the spit
situation thumbs up okay
good way though go by away it's good
plenty of spit before that I was in the
bathroom and before that I was getting
ready for the show when Joe to George
made the ET running through the
cornfield
noise before that I was eating like the
best sandwich ever that is the best
sandwich uh on the planet as far as I've
ever experienced if there's a better
sandwich on planet Earth I want somebody
to tell me about it personally I uh was
not as impressed it was all right
but I value structure in my sandwiches
no boo no no no the sloppier the better
that's the key that was half of the fun
really trying to battle that sandwich
part of what I like about sandwiches is
the handheld nature of them we haven't
actually told anyone what the sandwich
was no they don't need to know we can't
let them know it was a candy sandwich
made out of candy and sponge sugar and
candy gummy worms Band-Aids before that
I was purchasing some exceptionally
expensive cold brewed Japanese coffee it
tastes like a chocolate almost before
that though I was driving around
Seattle before that I was eating Doritos
and before that I was listening to Joe
de George and Neil Cera interpret the ET
theme before that I was eating Dick's
Hamburgers Hank Green stuffing himself
with and before that I was driving from
Olympia to Seattle with the help of
Andrew
WK all right before that I was listening
to Harry and the Potters in Olympia and
before that I was playing my own show in
Olympia and then before that I was
washing down a corn dog with water from
an artisian well and just before that I
was eating a corn dog and before that I
was sleeping in the house of an amazing
artist Nicole georgees who drew some
kind of amazing ET art on Paul and Joe's
shirts and then before that we were
packing up the van before that we were
playing some music in Portland and you
know before that I was getting off a
plane from Missoula and I didn't take
any footage of that the time I spent in
all of those places was so brief and so
fast and so intense that I didn't have
very many thoughts from them but now
with with a bit of perspective I have
some pretty serious thoughts that we all
need to get out and live life as much as
we can that the amount of Happiness we
have has very little to do with the
amount of money that we have and that
the amount of awesome per person seems
to be universally pretty high it was a
pleasure to meet all of the people that
I met in the last week I had a blast and
if you came out I hope that you had a
really good time too John I'll see you
on
Tuesday oh and also the Mars science
laboratory is landing this weekend and
I'm extremely excited about it click
here to watch the S Show video about the
entry descent and landing and join me
Sunday night I'll be live tweeting from
the siow Twitter